with rapid population growth and
unsustainable practices by 2030 we're
projected to experience a 40% shortfall
in fresh water I'm Stanford Professor
will tpe and in my new course I will
demystify the World of Water Management
and chemical manufacturing together
we'll explore the promise of circular
economies and reveal the pivotal roles
that water plays from producing fuels
and fertilizers to making the very water
that we consume every day unlock the
future of water treatment by diet into
the groundbreaking realm of
electrochemical Wastewater refining
we'll also immerse ourselves in
Innovative Realms of on-site treatment
and autonomous sensing join me Professor
William tarpe and let's Embark together
on a path of Discovery Innovation and
sustainability